les femmes sont encore rares hauts
sommets du monde des affaires
selon la présidente de l'organisme la
gouvernance au féminin il est grand
temps de forcer la main des entreprises
quand on met en place des lois quand on
légifère on trouve les femmes
et quand on ne légifère pas on trouve
les excuses légiférer la france l'a déjà
fait en obligeant les entreprises cotées
en bourse d'avoir 40 % de femmes sur
leur conseil d'administration avant 2017
voilà pourquoi dans le monde hommes du
jeu vidéo chez ubisoft
le ca est paritaire le rôle d'un conseil
administration s'est donné une direction
après ce bain notre travail à nous cette
faille en soit on construit cette vision
l'ops vers cette direction là voilà cinq
ans qu'ubisoft va encore plus loin et
tente de recruter davantage de femmes
d'employés de tous les horizons
ici on sait que la diversité est payante
des entreprises qui sont diverses
fonctions diversifiés sont plus
productives
il ya différents points de vue
différents de le choc des idées tout ça
tout le monde dit que c'est une très
bonne nouvelle brique ça donne des
résultats qui sont concrets sont les
conseils d'administration des sociétés
d'état ou your own parité entre les
femmes et les hommes qui meurent c'est
cette même logique qui avait incité le
gouvernement charest oblige il 22
sociétés d'état du québec avoir des
conseils paritaire mais les progrès
demeurent timides depuis 2015 au canada
le nombre de femmes sur les conseils
d'administration des entreprises cotées
en bourse est passé d'à peine 11% à 14%
pour la présidente du ca de
l'industrielle alliance c'est aberrant
c'est non seulement pour beaucoup c'est
un peu déprimant et ses organisations
sont capables de faire beaucoup mieux
le débat n'est pas est-ce qu'ils sont x
qui doivent faire mieux oui parce qu'ils
peuvent faire - mieux oui la question
c'est quel est le moyen d'assurer le
plus de progrès avec pérennité il est
bien là le débat car les modes s'ils
voient dans ce piètre bilan
la preuve d'un échec je ne sais pas
comment il justifierait de ne pas
accepter cette proposition
elle compte sur le premier ministre
trudeau pour appuyer
est mise de l'avant par un groupe de
sénateurs de forcer les entreprises à se
doter d'objectifs précis d'échéancier
par exemple chiffres à l'appui les
celles qui ont des cibles en 26 % de
femmes au conseil et celles qui n'ont
pas ti-blanc 12 % de femmes au conseil
donc c'est évident que les entreprises
qui disent bon on va suivre un
échéancier
on veut tant de femmes d'ici telle date
etc vont mettre en place les mesures
nécessaires pour que ça arrive et celle
qui espère que dans l'air du temps
quelque chose va changer ma il se passe
rien
or le monde des affaires est allergique
aux quotas réfractaire aux objectifs
fermes en matière de diversité
même chez l'industrielle alliance
pourtant modèle avec son conseil
d'administration paritaire les formules
mathématiques c'est simple tout le monde
les comprends mais ça mène à certaines
aberrations
moi je trouve qu'un objectif de
diversité représenter les hommes et les
femmes de d1 intelligente d'expériences
et de compétences diversifiées un
objectif plus difficile à atteindre
c'est ainsi que même chez ubisoft là où
le recrutement de main-d'oeuvre
diversifié est une priorité
on préfère miser sur la culture
d'entreprise plutôt que sur des cibles
faire on a une stratégie justement de
petits petit train va loin
puis on veut progresser on est engagé
dans cette progression là mais pour moi
ça me paraît plus plus durable ou plus
solides comme stratégie 4x un object